madame monsieur bonsoir 53 minutes pour
montrer sa détermination à remettre la
France en marche Dominique de villeepin
n'a pas voulu choisir aujourd'hui entre
la voie libérale ou sociale son
idéologie l'action un discours critiqué
par la gauche et par l'UDF le point avec
Benoît
Mousset monsieur le Premier ministre
vous avez la parole c'est l' preuve
initiatique de tout premier ministre le
discours de politique générale le grand
oral tant attendu pour Dominique de
villep qui doit convaincre et séduire
les députés de sa majorité devant les
difficultés qu' l'attendent Dominique de
Villepin affiche d'emblé sa
détermination avec vous représentants de
la
nation je veux fixer les repères tracer
la voix remettre la France en marche
8 jours après sa nomination à Matignon
la priorité reste la même la bataille
pour l'emploi avec un message
d'équilibre entre solidarité et
liberté dans une démocratie moderne le
débat n'est pas entre le libéral et le
social il est en vérité
entre
l'immobilisme et
l'action je choisis
résolument le parti de l'action nous
devons faire est donc à la mobilisation
générale sur le fond comme sur la forme
le Premier ministre ne s'est accordé
qu'une seule envolée lyrique en 50
minutes de
discours nos paysages nos campagnes nos
villages font notre fierté l'Outremer
apporte à notre pays l'amitié du Proche
et le CEL du
lointain fin de l'exercice sous les
applaudissements des bandes de l'UMP
mais pas de l'UDF malgré quelques
réserves dans son camp la confiance est
accordée à Dominique de Villepin avec
comme seul mot d'ordre l'unité derrière
le gouvernement
la déclaration de politique générale du
Premier ministre a été l'occasion pour
les députés UMP d'entendre ce qu'il
souhaitait entendre l'UDF en revanche
avait déjà prévenu qu'elle ne voterait
pas la confiance à la tribune son chef
explique le pourquoi vous avoir nommé à
l'Hôtel Matignon c'était forcément
choisir la continuité peut-on sortir du
système avec ceux qui ont fait le
système je ne le crois pas
l'idée à gauche pas de surprise les
critiques sont sévères avec même une
mise en garde quant à la
méthode si vous décidez par ordonnance
de toucher au code du travail c'est un
conflit avec le pays que vous prenez la
responsabilité d'ouvrir à la rentrée
tonalité identique pour le parti
communiste qui prévoit même la fin
prochaine du gouvernement
villepain la période d'essès de 2 ans
présenté comme un progrès c'est
absolument scandaleux d'ailleurs je
pense au passage que en ce qui le
concerne monsieur de Villepin ne frera
peut-être pas sa période déessès de 2
ans 100 jours c'est le temps que s'est
fixé Dominique de Villepin pour redonner
confiance au français un Premier
ministre qui sait déjà que l'assemblée
ne lui accordera aucun état de
grâce